when he was sending me Jango he actually
didn't want to tell me that I wasn't
going to be Jango I don't want to tell
you but all right well the character is
Steven so and I was like well who is
Stephen he said just read the script and
then when I read the script I called him
back and said so you want me to be the
most despicable NE cinematic history and
we were both kind of like laughed
together said yeah yeah let's get on
that he has enough problem being
vilified himself as a racist because he
uses [__] in his scripts that much or
puts those kinds of words in a
character's mouth but you know I always
tell people I don't understand why they
can't look at his work and realize that
every character he's ever given me has
pretty much been the smartest character
in the film that has the most dignity
and respect and kind of runs things and
is not a fool of any sort and
understands a whole lot about what's
going on in life and in the world and
for him to write characters like that
for me would be impossible for a racist
to do